madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
c'est sousemprise que nous abordons
aujourd'hui le projet de loi de finances
pour l'année
2023 nous sommes mes chers collègues
sous l'emprise de l'article
493 qui est certes constitutionnel mais
qui muselle les organes de la démocratie
représentative nous avons donc à nous
prononcer sur un budget animé par des
logiques quasi schizophrénique tant
votre souci de maintenir à flot
l'économie par diverses aides se heurte
à votre volonté de commencer à instaurer
une austérité qui ne veut pas dire son
nom car ne nous y trompons pas il faut
bien considérer cette loi de finance
pour ce qu'Al est le deuxème budget le
plus austéritaire des 20 dernières
années une fois neutralisé l'impact de
la fin des mesures exceptionnelles liées
au
covid-19 les 65000 milliard d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires prévu suffisent
tout juste à couvrir le coût de
l'inflation ces 20 dernières années une
seule fois le budget des services
publics aura connu restriction plus
importantes par rapport à l'année
précédente en
2018 quelques mois avant la crise des
gilets jaunes comprendra qui
voudra je le dis ce budget aura un
impact sur des tensions sociales déjà
substantielles tout comme il aura un
impact à court terme sur l'état de nos
services publics et donc sur la réforme
aux besoins de la
population derrière ces arbitrages
budgétaires c'est notre capacité à
préparer collectivement l'avenir qui est
en jeu un avenir dont nos élus dans les
territoires peinent à tracer des
contours radieux le donner des marges de
manœuvre est vitale car il ne demande
pas l'omone mais simplement la capacité
à penser le futur
sereinement voote l'amendement que je
porterai au nom du groupe socialiste sur
l'indexation de la DGF sur
l'inflation participe de cette
sérénité si nécessaire